hey everyone infinity day has arrived
Avengers infinity war has released
worldwide and we all saw it and we're
pretty speechless
Thanos doesn't have to demand our
silence but you know we are here with
our full review this episode here is
taught us talking about the different
aspects of infinity war and we're gonna
try to warn you before we talk about
this movies ending and other spoilery
plot points but to be safe it's best to
consider this whole video is yeah I
actually did another deliberately
non-spoiler review that he write
yesterday if you haven't seen the movie
yet you can check that out
and then go see the movie enemies back
here cool welcome to new rockstars news
everyone soar deep dive into all the
biggest stories from this week of course
infinity war is the biggest toriel this
week but we're also gonna get to some
quick updates about Aquaman and Wonder
Woman the sequel because the DCU is
still a thing we'll get to it well I'm
Erik Bosse in joining me at this table
are my personal Avengers the young buck
hi I'm Alina nice to well guys Maude
Garrett was here a second ago but then
she like looked at us sadly and just
faded into ash oh I don't know what's
going on she did say I don't want to go
mr. Molina and then Eric stole my joke
that's pretty good joke you had a
different version of the joke and I
twisted it anyway mods Ronnie and Maude
will be back well they'll all be there
he'll be back
we'll get to that let's start let's get
start with our review of Avengers
infinity war there is just so much to
talk about guys and we are here with our
deeper thoughts and again we'll try to
warn me before we can do a big spoiler
spoiler review but you know just protect
yourself and assume this is don't make
it our responsibility let's start with
the ways infinity war won the victories
highlights the things that just blew us
away and just really impressed us about
this movie
you think I'll just save favorite
characters Thor Gomorrah and Scarlet
Witch personally Gomorrah is the most
she's ever had to do ever
and she was like thought out besides
being somewhat of a like babysitter kind
of to the guy like the babies of the
guardians you know they're all like like
Drax just doesn't understand stuff
star-lord yeah reference is like a
sitcom wife yeah and this it's like no
she gets a lot to do and in Thor it's
like you actually get to deal with the
rent like that what happened in Ragnarok
it's like yeah I found out I had a
sister my father kept her from me and
then she died and lost my dad I lost my
mom my brother and he died in front of
me and it's like and for a second this
new thought of who I really enjoy that I
like the fun Thor more than what the
other plain Thor we had in like the
first two years this one I like more
because there's more to him and I enjoy
that we actually ought to explore that
and he got some of the most epic moments
in this also Scarlet Witch envisioned
actually being you we got to experience
this kind of like Shakespearean
relationship between the two of them
like not being able to be together but
they're still trying and think about
running away together I am glad that we
got to explore that to some extent in
this movie yeah it it was interesting I
while watching even though this was a
bulky massive movie with lots of
different even plot lines that they
would have to spend like half an hour
away from before coming back to I felt
like in a lot of ways we explored more
of these characters like psychologies
and their arcs and their backstories
then some of their like solo movies it
like I feel like I learned more about
Thor in this movie than I did in Thor
Ragnarok that's not true for all the
characters but they really did a good
job balancing everyone and that was
Herculean feat if you think we've never
seen a movie like but but ironically
it's actually not about something so
difficult it's about pairing way down an
efficiency in every moment you have with
someone it's like realize this is one of
ten lines this character gets in this
movie maybe
and I'll say actually maybe one of those
times I actually think maybe she
shouldn't have that put a joke it's like
give us one more line that is actually
like impactful even though I think this
movie actually mostly balanced the
comedy way better than some of the other
ones had but it's just they knew exactly
we have one chance usually with every
character let's go down and Princeton
black widow is a good example of like
they have a second of oh right
she had a whole thing with Bruce and has
seen him again is bringing back all
these feeling and like movie we were
we're on something else they had to be
so superficial
aside from that what I think worked
amazingly sure the movies incredibly
epic and it had to be and actually lived
up to that which is great the thing that
none of us were talking about and as
soon as I thought I was like holy crap
they nailed it and I forgot that's the
most important thing they did Danno so
well and so we've talked about like his
origins to know ya ad nauseam and we and
I think this is the best version you
could possibly do of what Thanos is
basic ideologies or what his main goal
is it's like abridged in comics he wants
to impress death who's a female being
Indian is and to do so he kills half the
universe but in this it's like there
even though he's crazy
and he's wrong you see the logic in it
and that you see that there's pain in
him by like choosing to rinse opposed to
choosing Gamora
the stone over Gamora like that's it
hurts but deep down he knows that if he
can make the sacrifice it's gonna mean a
lot more down at least he thinks it's
gonna mean right down the line and it's
most what is in one of their noses big
things is like having a kid death that
means something right they like they
tell people like don't worry your death
means something you gotta kill my Panos
so he obviously thinks it is like a good
place to send her but doing the villains
justice a lot of times to do with their
motivation right and Danis could have so
easily been just another almost called
him Ramone I'm blanket from does this
thing it's the same thing that made the
character of the wrestler in the film
the wrestler oh yeah it's so fascinating
it's that obsession with his own he's
this powerful figure and he has his
daughter who hates him yeah in that
movie and in the wrestler we watch that
and we see that it's the one thing that
like Pierce's him harder than anything
else that is our darkness you also get
that maybe in Logan a little bit right
like Logan is so far gone
this one little girls like the one thing
that it's like oh that still has a
direct strain to my heart and so giving
us that with Gomorrah made Gomorrah way
more interesting than she'd ever been
but also grounded the biggest villain in
all of the MCU as well as they could
have and again is that's probably why
they had to give me so much damn screen
time yeah it's really thanasis movie
like if it's hard with you know so many
different characters to pinpoint who is
the main protagonist of this film or
even who is the main team of me it's him
it's nano stano's career goal he changes
the most over the course of this story I
wouldn't I would argue like he has a
clearest journey it's like throughout
like making difficult decision from the
beginning to the end his expression at
the end of the film there's almost like
a bit of regret there like worthy again
and and be rooting for Thanos yeah and
it's typically structured like your
average movie which like man I hope he
pulls this off the universe needs at the
end he's like there's a lot of people
been comparing it to the Empire Strikes
Back of the MCU this movie it's a very
bleak note but it in a way Empire
Strikes Back kind of feels like the
movie where you get to know Vader a lot
more he's less of this dark mysterious
figure and you start to get under his
skin and see what his relationship is
there is that parental relationship
there that you starts to make sense and
contextualize the character a bit more
and I think if you but it also in some
ways makes me remember how much of the
mid sections of Empire Strikes Back I
kinda was like alright I'm ready to move
on to the next thing but the ending
makes it all worth it there's just kind
of like dark bleak ending and it kind of
reminds us no not everything has to have
like a simple Hollywood ending things
can end in this way that like leaves us
with a gut punch so you have to do it in
the way that they did this it personally
it's better than I think they did in the
comics where it was just it's instant
it's what starts everything that we got
this event usually is one issue and then
the four other issues of a five issue
series is like is gonna be part two of
whatever the story is so the way they
chose to end in the way they chose to
visualize it hurt a lot more than when I
I did a quick like read-through of the
infamous darling when he does this which
is sure you can read
yes really short and it's just he snaps
and people kind of scream out of
existence which is scary but now this
it's like it's more hopeless that's
terrifying this is just like nothing
there's literally nothing you can do
right now it's completely random what
who is staying and who was going random
right like conveniently the six cirrage
are there at the end to the old timers
are there to clean up stuff goodbye I do
really
I do enjoy that they did that because
there's a couple different ways you
could have done this or like some people
when I left the movie were like upset
too like why would they choose to like
off the new people when like and they're
the next generation it's like it's
because you have 20 you're gonna have 20
movies that are a full arc of Tony Stark
and Captain America and Thor and you get
to wrap that up in one of the most epic
sagas they've ever put to film and I
think that's a really cool way to do is
that they get one last ride and also if
you want to pull a classic sci-fi comic
book II trope make evil versions of you
bring them back to life just to like
fight the guy that is bizarre but if you
look at it it's like it's Bucky versus
like Bucky Groot Drax mantis Doctor
Strange Scarlet Witch it's like it's a
lot of that's a lot of heavy hitters
yeah let it go up against the old-timers
yeah and you brought up the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline and I think you can
see this in the other review video that
I did I think watching this movie that
is to me the biggest highlight is it
rewards fans who have been sticking with
this series since the beginning and the
way that a good comic book crossover
issue does its hopefully also
entertaining to people who are just
picking up this one issue for the first
time but it also pays off little inside
jokes and past character team upset and
parallels between characters and Men
this movie is filled with little winks
to the MCU past movies little joke
callbacks that like thinking about on
the ride home like alright that was uh
that was a guardians of the galaxy joke
yeah to like the limb thing which
personally I didn't find that funny way
in both Guardians movies this I was like
that's great because it pays off in a
cool way and also you get a great joke
with Bucky picking up rocket and they
get that you gotta teach that you're
like I didn't need this but I'm so happy
I got it but also getting I feel bad
talking about it but his spoilers
Red Skull like the
tiny like paying that off fans we didn't
need that we yeah that was one of our
more piercings from months ago that we
brought up was like and you know what
they could bring back Red Skull yeah and
I like oh man if somebody could find it
I feel like the context of that
conversation was like who knows maybe he
has a soul stone I feel like I feel like
and also like something I love the
reason it was just like yeah I messed
with it too much
yeah about red skull by the way so that
was not Hugo Weaving who was the actor
who portrayed the red skull previously
and the Captain America movie he said he
really never wants to come back can do
that yeah but the actor there was Ross
mark and who you might remember from The
Walking Dead Aaron is an amazing
impressionist so he did a Hugo Weaving
impression but if you look him up also
he has just great impression Tia did a
video for variety or something not long
ago oh the micro impressions yeah maybe
you might have PTSD - I saw you I saw I
snapped and you like looked at me here
like no but I so real quick fun thing
about him he used to work for us oh yeah
if you if you find way back unless I
private of them all we still draw my
news and he would do all the voices for
it and now he's red skull that's amazing
good for you but that was an amazing
payoff and I like that that we see like
there's consequences there's there
there's serious consequences and even
though they announced he goes off to the
farm I like that you saw that like the
gauntlet it's not he made it he and I
like that that they brought that up it's
like it's not like a thing that was
floating around right tracked it down
and he chose to make it because he
wanted to use them all together because
he knew that these existed how can we do
it and it's like you don't it's not
gonna be as easy as someone else
slipping it back on it it's gonna take a
lot of work in the next movie yeah real
quick something fun about that that a
lot of people don't realize is it's not
so much that it's like oh he could do
this or this or this or this or this
things can happen along the lines of the
Power Stone can charge the time stone it
can it can empower the soul stone so
he can actually like in there
combination create something that like
getting rid of the life half the life in
the universe so some people are like all
they need back is the time stone so it's
actually way more difficult to undo what
was done interesting it's like a piano
keyboard he could play like see yeah he
played a chord
yeah it's it's interesting that this is
a movie about like sacrifice you know I
think that was kind of the unifying
theme of all the characters is it worth
it to do this is it worth Tony Stark to
to go through and even though Pepper
Potts he's about to get married to her
know like yeah he has to go through with
this right now even Thanos is like
burden my sacrifice by the end the movie
it seems like there's a bit of doubt in
his eyes on whether or not like all of
this struggle was truly worth it but
also you kind of get the feeling of like
you're too far gone like you you've done
too much also just pointing this out
Thanos is the only one that got any of
the stones right like he's the only
besides evany MA putting strange in the
ship Stannis is the only one who ever
got the stones he got so they went we
don't know how he got the power stone
but we're assuming that he let's assume
he just wiped out the yeah yeah and then
they all together they wouldn't got the
space stone then the reality stone he
got by himself the soul stone he had to
get by himself and the mind stone is the
one he physically gotten himself and the
time stone he had - that was him by
himself yeah interesting to see how each
stone successfully led to his
acquisition of the next stone you know I
was I would have been kind of cool to
see him use his soul stone in there's a
chance that he's a soul stone in a
couple of ways I feel like there are
some moments that might have been so
stunned about and if in a fighting way I
would say that might have been how he
was able to know which was the real
Doctor Strange it's like basically then
also I think that's why he has the
understanding of Tony Stark of course it
could also be like oh who led the army
that defeated my army or something like
oh well here's Tony Stark here's a
report but I think it's actually the
soul stone actually has the power to
give you knowledge of all souls yeah he
is I've also cursed by knowledge right
so now he actually knows oh I think that
my cool but so I think there are some
instances a soul stone usage but
actually great there's not a ton there's
also some stuff about so stone giving
you the ability to speak with the dead
which might be what's happening the
resurrection stone from Harry Potter
like basically it's though it's the
stuff yeah it's just like hey just so
you know this is what you're doing like
you're using you're doing something you
shouldn't and the soul stone is just a
safeguard it's like a are you sure yeah
I'm gonna show you your files real quick
yeah I would say just like being moving
on to a couple little gripes because
this isn't a perfect film it's hard you
can find all kinds of reasons to like
just disagree with this choice but I
would say that like that just a general
criticism at the entire MCU they could
have done a slightly better job
clarifying what each stone does and what
its power is and the way it is in this
movie it's a little similar to like the
Horcruxes of Harry Potter which we
brought up as an example or the Deathly
Hallows - where they're all just like
kind of equal different powers this
movie made a couple choice I love the
way the reality stone was used that felt
like it was wasting out of the comics
but like there are times where he's like
just using especially in these fights
later in the film where it's just like
oh why are you just using the purple
stone when you can like turn everyone
into marbles you know like wouldn't that
be a more interesting right it was kind
of constant power stone yes seems like
power stones that there is something
that helps address that a little bit
because one of my issues with it with
the film is that I think that the whole
gauntlet got nerfed a little works like
oh it can do all of these things but
he's mostly gonna punch you know like
that I did I did get that feeling I was
trying to think specifically about the
reality stone how he was you know he can
dice you up and turn you into cubes it's
like yeah do that to everybody
immediately that's even walking up to
you but then I had to admit that they
think of a lot honestly going into this
they wrote a character who does not get
joy out of killing he did joy out of
fighting his fights are pretty lazy
honestly I except for the
few moments where he's actually
challenged and then he like steps it up
a little bit but he purposely kind of
just like is holding back constantly and
it's because I think they did a good job
of explaining he doesn't want to do it
he feels that he has to do it he wants
to do it justly and fairly so he's only
gonna kill the half that he wants to
kill which begs the question dads
Guardians if he did already kill half of
them when he did this thing did they get
reduced down to a quarter the ship look
like it was ripped in half so he he the
door in the fridge where there there's
no engine in this part but you guys will
figure out were there any other things
that you guys felt like came up a little
short for you or something you wanted
more from the movie they're being honest
if you look at this purely from a film
critic standpoint there is ZERO entry
for someone who does not has not watched
almost every film and I think the films
you could watch and get away with this
is like Doctor Strange seemed to
understand that like otherworldly things
guardians to galaxy vol 2 civil war and
Thor Ragnarok I feel like that's those
movies could get you into this one
you'll understand enough of it but uh-oh
but overall it's like this there's a it
does ask you to to know a lot going into
it I don't find that to be a problem
because this is an experiment there's
never been a movie like this before
so I appreciate that it's like you know
we're expecting you to be kind of to be
invested in this like it and if you're
not you're gonna get some some awesome
fight scenes which you got some amazing
moments you actually got some character
depth and you get on at least enough
information to understand the characters
that do get them the biggest arc in it
like yeah when like Mike Panther shows
up it's like it's a bummer that he's not
utilized that much it's kind of it's
just like what Connors just mainly a
set-piece because they're like we cannot
decimate a city again we know that you
have room here and also we can work with
like try to say vision over here like it
makes sense that we're here but like I
don't know there's a lot of weird
elements and I feel like if you were
just going into this with no knowledge
you have a hard time understanding this
movie and
yeah yeah what just reminds me of
watching you know games doesn't get you
the red wedding episode and then your
friend brings his girlfriend that's like
sitting there and she's like do we like
those people or no and it's like no they
just killed our baby like like you kind
of have to be like yeah this is chapter
what 18 19 or Dever of a very long story
sorry but on other films I definitely
see they should all be entries right
feel like this one's like well don't
home tune in on the season finale entry
it's not the Superbowl episode you know
the super episode they're always like
reminder everyone's names really quick
my beef though I gave you that I thought
the Infinity Gauntlet was a little
weaker than I wanted it to be any
could've used it but they could they
have an interesting reason why not but I
have two specific ones one is maybe half
nitpicky and one they couldn't have done
anything about the half no picky thing
is that they were one I mean I hate to
be the one that calls it up but their
one degree too funny the movies have
been getting consistently funnier and I
love funny movies and I totally get that
but comedy by definition relieves
tension so when you have a film that's
infinity war and it's about ratcheting
up the tension and making it worse on
your characters and we're like you know
I can't breathe and we're feeling you
know that that sensation of that like it
reminds me of in spider-man homecoming
when you think he's gonna die and it's
like he's like what a way to go we're
sinners cracked a joke right there the
tension lead the air limousine I feel
like like that right now has way too
much of that this movie had only one
degree too much of that like I
legitimately was like overall pretty
much nailed it but they later in the
movie it's so tense that I want it to
stay tense so one I'll just call out is
for instance it didn't it doesn't matter
so small but acknowledging Thor's
haircut like a haircut like oh you're
copying my beard and it's like guys like
we're so far into this right now no it's
not the time like dude like the most
important thing to you in the world
should be achieving your goal and the
moment you go to make a joke it turns
out that was the most important thing to
you in the world in that moment making a
joke is more important that's my like
thing that sorry I do know that's fair
to point out and also but
for me for the most part I think the
humor was used just enough like the
example that I feel like was that they
kind of like captured both the tension
and the comedy in a really good way it
was when the cue ship landed in New York
and there in the sanctum and they're
like you doing that with your hair on
purpose like it's right good joke but
also it's like there's a little fear
there where you're like that's perfect
right because is comedy getting those
moments in real life when you're having
like a real serious or sad moment you
might crack a joke but you don't leave
the moment to do it you do it from
inside at the moment yes you're between
characters you're trying to relieve the
tension among it's that nervous laughter
before something bad happens
and that's are bad things that happen we
kind of want for how far thor ragnarok
went in that direction they actually
almost weren't it's like they wouldn't
have been allowed to go a hundred
percent back to Avengers 1 where the
biggest joke they can make is in the
post-credit scene we're imagine that
trauma of course in thor ragnarok he
would easily walk out the other issue I
had was the one they couldn't control
why do we know so much about the damn
sequels that are already in production
and like it's like just that such a cold
moment they offer oh my god spider-man's
gone and it's like oh and then Kevin
Feige at the premiere of this same movie
was talking about like oh man homecoming
is gonna be you know set in Paris and so
it's like the sequel to it and it's like
right they're all fine right and black
panther 2 will happen when and that's
that might just be like us within our
bubble that we're reading this stuff all
the time because we like to talk about
with you guys but it's it's a little
tough yeah especially when you were a
Marvel head Kevin Feige yeah he's been
so tight-lipped about everything else
right been so secretive about phase 4
just you know if we could have really
had that question like will we ever see
Tom Holland again it's also a bit on Tom
Holland right didn't he say in an
interview during spider-man homecoming
like so it's gonna be a trilogy we knew
he was coming back but I do agree and I
think that whole idea of the ending
fixed a lot of issues for me like I
think my my biggest gripe is just it's
too crowded of a movie it jumps around a
lot I think they did the best possible
job they could have done they
surprisingly did a really good job with
pacing and balance it's just a lot it's
a lot and there was a specific
where it's like oh it's been 35 minutes
since I've seen an Iron Man I forgot
he's part of this movie that might have
just been me in the way I personally
valued certain story lines of her others
but I think the ending of the film
fixed a lot of that on a meta level and
within the story like it makes me really
excited going into Avengers 4 seeing a
streamlined trimmed down version of this
cast many of whom probably will not
return beyond that movie leaving it to
this next generation which is currently
benched for this final showdown
hopefully just benched so that they can
later take over and be the stars in the
next generation but for now I thought
there was a lot of jumping around and I
think it seemed like heaven Vike it was
a bit like you know we kind of over
populated this universe let's just make
it harder on them and fade them all away
for a little bit so that we can have a
more interesting kind of retro showdown
the way it was in the first degree even
though that's what you want
I've done it for me for the next movie
I'm like please give me every character
you've ever written as part of the MCU
on-screen in the same place at the same
time we talked about like some
characters that have already been
confirmed from write movie so I think
hopefully yeah what will happen is we'll
get some big splash page type scene
where just everyone well we're gonna
talk more about like this movie's indie
and exactly what it means and how it
will lead to the next movie later in
this show
but let us know what you liked and what
you wanted more from from this movie in
the comments below and yeah if you could
just do us a favor I know this is a
spoiler review but not everyone really
pays attention to that in the comments
it just to protect everyone in these
first like 72 hours of first week
just mark any comments that you do write
with major plot points but like spoiler
just you know cover your bases just you
know so you don't start any fights and
just be try to be courteous and raise
disability on your side hopefully people
respond that way anyway let's move on
for right now for to this week's trivia
question oh and I think we got a good
one from
he wore to test our immediate recently
okay here we go in Avengers infinity war
Tony Stark brags at Ben and Jerry's
named an ice cream flavor after him
stark raving hazelnuts Wong responds
that he prefers another flavor what was
the name of that flavor all right we got
all of our answers here in our cauldron
of the cosmos here the answer the trivia
question and the closes answer has
decided by our judges will do or sign up
good byes at the end of the video
meanwhile the loser will have to
cleverly riff on or in other news
headlines okay let's move on now before
we actually get to more Infinity Ward
news let's quickly check in on an update
on the Aquaman movie director James Wan
does not want us to be talking about it
right yeah James Wan described the
movie's plot this week as a
Shakespearean sibling rivalry between
Arthur curry Jason Momoa Aquaman and his
brother Orme ocean master Patrick Wilson
early footage was shown at CinemaCon and
it showed the two in a gladiator type
match at an undersea Coliseum and
Atlantis along with other shots of
Aquaman saving the submarine in a battle
featuring men riding sharks cool we'll
see that footage in a trailer soon we
just want to update you guys on that now
so that you're in the know next okay
everybody now that Avengers infinity war
is out in the world the biggest question
on everybody's minds is what now
how will the story continue to play out
in adventures for which by the way is
scheduled to come out a year from now
may 3rd 2019 let's go to sleep we're
gonna actually get into some predictions
for Avengers 4 but in order to do that
yeah we're gonna have to talk about this
movie's ending so if you haven't seen
infinity war yet yeah spoilers ahead
just pause this video and then meet us
back here in the future ok cool
yeah all right nanos axe
going through with his plan to wipe out
half the universe gave us one of the
bleakest endings and cliffhangers that
we've ever seen in a movie ever I think
so let's recap the death toll for all of
you first characters we saw fully die in
infinity war not just fade away but like
not have a pulse
even Loki Heimdall Gamora and vision
yikes
and then there was the characters that
were caught in Thanos's like snap wave
you know fading away into dust in the
film's final mats your snap the universe
with some of our comments pointed out in
whatever videos like I don't think this
is gonna be able to snap in a metal
glove okay so these are the fader or
where's Black Panther the Spider Man
Scarlet Witch Bucky the Winter Soldier
Doctor Strange Falcon
star-lord Peter quill Drax Groot and
mantis along with Nick Fury and Maria
hill in the post-credits scene but now
the survivors as we know them right now
are Iron Man Captain America Thor Bruce
Banner
Black Widow war machine nebula rocket
Ocoee in Baku now we're not sure about
Sheree and Wong but we didn't see them
fade away so I'm guessing they're okay
hopefully Hawkeye and ant-man were with
their families during this whole mess
our Scott was on house arrest as war
machine said the wasp is probably still
around as well she'll be in the movie
with Scott Lang and as we saw the movie
is set before the events of that's what
we've all been theorizing because that
would make could you imagine we also saw
in the post credit final image
Captain Marvel Carol Danvers will be
joining the beeper yeah and check out
our post credit scene breakdown for all
that info and of course Thanos the mad
Titan was the victor in this battle but
you know what not the war I know it's
early but let's discuss some predictions
of how the surviving team could avenge
the Fallen in Avengers 4 Oh first stop
real quick before we even dive into
specifics I feel like we need to divide
it like there's only a couple of
categories we could even look at four
possibilities like I'll throw it right
away obviously it's like okay
about time travel that's a category that
could be it happening to maybe like
using the time stone to rewind the time
travel just for a little bit what are
our time travel options okay time travel
here's a plus theory they get the
defenders and specifically Iron Fist
time travel back in time right before
the snap he gets the I first slips it
right between the fingies in the in the
pointer finger to do the snap and he's
like I'm finally important and then they
know skills them and then it happens all
over again now real theories like no
matter what I say have said will say
anything Iron Fist still that's gonna be
some power involving the mine stone
seems like the the first go-to idea
right because time time stone what I
said my said time stone yeah yeah be
thank you the in the comics the Infinity
Gauntlet comics that's essentially how
it works there's a character who gets a
hold of the gauntlet and uses it to
basically rewind the clock a day with
without spoiler spoiling the comic
series I'll say that Adam warlock that
isn't the entirety of the rest of this I
think is based on him coming into play
and changing everything that happens
what schools I think it's not gonna go
that way because that character has
barely been touched on and he's tough
he's like space Jesus it's a super
honesty I think in this movie slate we
they would have had to be in another
movie to introduce that character so I
don't think it's gonna go that Adam
warlock but so the time stone is one way
to go back in time but it does it does
talk about maybe essentially it's going
and getting it from Thanos essentially
cutbacks and taking the gauntlet back
something like that also throw out there
the possibility of dealing with an
eternal like Chronos in the way that I
it
Dormammu kind of can be reasoned with a
little bit in Doctor Strange like maybe
it could be like hey don't you have
aren't you the embodiment of time can't
you I think time travel has some
possibilities yeah but in terms of the
ones we've actually seen established
it's really a time stone right like that
kind of it seems that's one way you can
do anyway I think the theory that
usually whenever they go up and begin
stand-ups in a comic he usually is his
own worst enemy and you can kind of get
a hint of that and this is that he maybe
regrets part of what he did yeah he does
smile at the end to say so maybe he's
okay with what he did but I think
there's gonna come into play maybe a
discussion between Thanos and one of the
Avengers probably Tony because it's his
MCU where they there is something
there's reasoning with Thanos and I
think there might be an outside threat
because right now we don't know where
the stones are because they're not with
it from what I remember wasn't wearing
the gauntlet yeah so he could still have
it or they they you sometimes just
separate out and they go did it look
like I got it crumble crumble because
it's it's a lot of effort and it's the
the gauntlet itself is not this amazing
thing good thing it was just forged we
knew I was created by materialist which
was cool that yeah it was but I I think
to get a good arc for Thanos to really
kind of round this out is that he's the
one who fixes it is that he he says
backwards which is impossible yeah but
that can't you in the middle of reality
so you've snapped backwards anything
yeah but I think it's that you're gonna
get kind of a fake out where Tony Stark
and the Avengers maybe they get the
stones get kind of shot through time or
shot through the universe so our new
kind of nerfed team has to figure out
how to get them back together and they
do and maybe there's an outside threat
like I was saying that could be a threat
here that's not Bannos because there's
plenty of other people that do use these
all the time it's the fun little
activity people do but I think Tony
Stark's gonna maybe be up there too like
this is me like this is I've messed up
with Ultron I'm kind of responsible in a
way for the events of the first Avengers
movie because that was his tower that
opened the portal and heard New York
civil wars kind of his fault so maybe he
could have almost a Redemption arc in
that movie and the last second Thanos
SEPs and he doesn't and he gets to live
happily ever after in the soul stone or
in an afterlife and most of the universe
gets back to normal yeah I think you're
on to something I think there whatever
the solution with Thanos is the way his
character
was drawn out in this movie seems like
soft power is gonna be the way end up
like the guys already having a couple
doubts like he's not just like a crazy
maniacal villain he has reasons with
himself on whether or not this is the
right decision to make and yeah there
was that smile at the end of the movie
but it seems like this guy could be
reasoned with in the way that dr.
strange reason with Dormammu so for
those of you keeping track on our
chalkboard that's invisible or we got
time-travel options then we have getting
into Thanos his head yeah I put
separately you kind of touched on it but
I think just getting whole ahold of the
gauntlet and somebody else doing it that
to me is a whole category of
possibilities because I think it'd be so
cool to see who I mean in the comic
there's a lot of talk who's worthy of
wielding the gauntlet you know it's not
exactly the same as it can't be held by
someone I someone else could dare to
hold it but who should hold the gun it's
a really cool if that if we were to go
with that it you've got your main three
Thor cap and Iron Man and while this is
like Iron Man's universe built around
him so we would kind of make sense way
to use it you also have two other people
that are worthy of wielding weapons of
that much power so it could it could
come down to a very interesting scene
maybe they don't use it together because
sometimes you need more than one person
to like wield that much power or a
character who's an even greater threat
than Thanos takes it over to use to use
it for other purposes in banos to switch
sides yeah in the comics a lot of the
characters they've been translated to
different characters in the film but the
characters that are at Thanos his side
actually a lot of them have their own
sights on the gauntlet yeah yeah there's
also the idea of like rather than time
stone the reality stone zipping into
other realities where maybe these
characters are still alive I'm gonna put
that up on a different category yeah
because I think that's yeah alternate
realities and alternate dimensions and
there I'm gonna give you my darkest
theory o darkest timeline yeah it is it
is a Dan Harmon reference actually I
think it's there is a solution here it's
dark it's a Rick and Morty asks solution
they go to a time line where was the
exact other half very people they were
killed and they
urge them and technically they get
everyone back but we don't lose the fact
that everyone still did turn to ash yeah
that's a bit that kids still super dad
but but then we don't undo what this
movie did because that's one of the
hardest things I think gonna be pull off
say it was for instance option one up
here on our list time travel and they go
mmm-hmm it's like great the biggest
movie of all time was just undone how do
you feel satisfied by it it would feel a
little simple would be a bit like we
flew through a giant plot hole and we
save the movie you know but you're
dealing with a crazy plot device that
can do anything so but so so let's make
it matter that we did that instead of
like we can just see I'm not a huge fan
of the fact that they they when they set
back time a little bit because I think
like oh well I hope that thing comes
around in the next movie when something
bad happens and you know why don't we go
fix some of the other movies too and
come on this guy still can barely walk
yeah I thought was good the show Rick
and Morty intentionally never touches on
time-travel like there's a box on the
shelf in the back of the garage it says
time-travel stuff as an in-joke that
they never like then never do time
travel even though that the show's
characters are based on doc and Marty
from Back to the Future or like a really
gross parody version of that they chose
to only explore different realities
because that opens the world up and it
avoids some of those complicated plot
holes that you can fall into with time
travel I think using different realities
would be potentially a far more
interesting way to go in this finale for
more on it would be a whole other way to
address the fact that we can't deny that
we've seen these characters dressed in
their previous costumes behind the
scenes from from Avengers 1 if it's like
ok well maybe they actually go get them
from a different timeline and and in a
different moment in a different timeline
or something like that without having to
go back to their own ones yeah I'm very
excited for Avengers 4 I think it's
gonna be crazy and it's gonna be fun I
think they were so restrictive on what
they were able to do with this story by
having so many
characters and I think by bending the
herd down to just like the bare
essentials you may get a story that goes
in a lot of different crazier places now
that we're so prepped from all these
other MCU movies doing interesting bold
choices like now that you've killed off
half the characters you kind of open
yourself up to do whatever you want
almost in a way I where we're talking
about res like resolutions for like how
they could figure this all out but I
think if you guys want to we could maybe
toy with the idea of like how we're
gonna wrap up some of these characters
like stories because you haven't dealt
with Captain Ironman there that's an
Ironman wasn't even barely even
mentioned are you know week and but also
like I just let my brain but also banner
and Hulk you have that as well and so I
think there could be some really I feel
like you're gonna lose basically all
every single one of your main characters
but I think it's gonna be in a way each
of them uses a reality each of them
holds one of the stones and they use it
in tandem like they showed in the first
guardians movie where they all share one
of them share one of them they share the
power but it is a sacrifice it is it's
it's a one-way trip alright we're gonna
talk more about infinity war in just a
second I just want to get very very
quick update about some Wonder Woman
news this week director patty Jenkins
confirmed from from an interview that
the sequel will feature Diana in the
1980s whose confirms various hints at
the movies story would center around the
Cold War in the Soviet Union
remember Wonder Woman Asia's very slowly
so there's really no limit to really any
part of human history she could be
involved with Jenkins said that the in
the first movie your character was
considered a child among the Amazonians
despite being somewhere around eight
hundred years old there you go something
to look forward to
okay everyone one of the most
interesting characters to watch an
Avengers infinity war was star-lord
Peter quill aka Guardians Chris we're
gonna be touching on a plot point in the
movie here so again spoiler warning go
watch the movie great you're back okay
and of interest infinity to war one
really the thrilling fight sequence for
me showed the Avengers come closer than
ever to actually getting the best of
Thanos on Titan Iron Man spider-man
Doctor Strange star-lord Drax mantis and
nebula combine their strengths to
restrain Thanos
trapping him in a near comatose state as
Iron Man and spider-man tried to pull
off the Infinity Gauntlet from his hand
spider-man comes agonizingly close we
see that thing regal and slide by the
way we see it's a size of entirety of
Peter Parker garbage cans at this same
moment star-lord realizes what Thanos
did to acquire the soul stone sacrificed
Gamora Peter quill loses it any attacks
Thanos breaking him out of that
restraint allowing him to fight back
each of the Avengers and then Thanos
throws a moon at them and he overwhelms
Stark and it gets the time stone many
pieces out back to earth where he uses
that time stone to reverse Scarlet Witch
destroy and vanished visions mine stone
had he not gotten time stone he never
would have gotten the mine stone he
never would gotten all six his master
plan would have been foiled so this
brings up the question guys is this all
star Lords fault or who believed
star-lord kept his cool and stomached
his grief they could have gotten the
gauntlet and Thanos would have been
finished star-lord and the other unlucky
unlucky half of the universe would still
be here I don't know guys how much do
you think star-lord is to blame is this
impulsive anguish over Gamora worth this
mistake it's 100 percent is fault
completely entirely uh there's no doubt
about the fact that this moment is his
fault that they lose that moment mm-hmm
that moment is his fault but I'll say
that in all of the possibilities of what
could have happened that Doctor Strange
perceived if it's over 14 million he had
to absolutely gain the time stone in
this moment we see it again shown when
he trades Stark's life for it I feel
like this is actually Doctor Strange
allowing certain things to happen we
need him to hold on to the gauntlet and
he needs to leave here with the time
stone it's one of the it's the only of
the versions that it will possibly
happen this is the only one where we
will eventually win even though we'll
lose right now so do you think the
Doctor Strange knew that and did not
share the entire thing cuz he knew star
lore was gonna react that way I think so
I think there's no way they could have
told the team it's like you're gonna try
real hard but then star Lord's gonna
mess it up for all of it especially if
it involves star
eventually being one of the people to
fade away right and and I think that
answer comes also in that moment where
Tony's like what you let me like we're
not even y'all kind of yeah right didn't
it feel like for a second it's like that
didn't feel earned it didn't feel like
but he's now my best friend so I you
know we don't trade live or something it
didn't feel like that in that moment
it's because dr. strange is playing four
dimensional test but you know what I
mean yes totally on another level and
he's allowing events to take place
including letting him mess things up in
that moment for me I didn't think that
that specific part was planned I think
this was a genuine mistake that that
does actually you do bring up a good
point if you saw 14 million outcomes
there's not one where star-lord freaked
out but he found out his girlfriend got
killed by her dad but in from the way I
interpret it watching it like then now
you bring up a good point but after I
saw the movie I thought that honestly
this was just an outcome he hadn't seen
just yet and star-lord freaking out did
ruin the one way they could have gotten
out of this and in his and all the
futures he saw he saw that Tony Stark
might be the only one that could like
not it could be one of the only people
to figure out how to undo this so that's
why he is like we can't let him die
because he's one of our only hopes super
fascinating possibility and it's it's
really answered by a year belief of your
own answer here to the question did he
mean there's one time where we win this
thing
now or on the other side of half the
people vanishing yeah we win at the end
of infinity war two I think he was
looking at immediate there's I it's kind
of hard to look at like already when he
said fourteen million like way too many
time you look there way too many futures
that they just picked a big number of
the writers dead and I feel like it was
more immediate but you do bring up a
good point
so just depend it's it's interesting how
much do you want to consider dr. strange
to be omniscient and a God in this movie
as the screenwriter and the director of
the movie you're kind of a god you
decide who comes in when and how these
events unfold and I was
thinking about this like oh why have
nebula come back and oh they needed
nebula to be in the scene in this moment
so that she could confirm that Gamora
died because she was part of that
conversation earlier but if the
screenwriter knew that like I have a
feeling strange would know that as well
he knew that nebula needed to crash her
ship and to Titan in this moment and
help them restrain Tanis or a moment but
he also knew that that would involve her
sharing that information with star-lord
and that that could cause chaos I think
that vision yeah I think it's very
possible that star that Doctor Strange
saw in this one timeline in the future
where things work nebula in Tony Stark I
think the way the screenwriters paired
things down to just have the essential
members of the MCU there in that final
battle I think that's what strange saw
as well we're only gonna have the people
who survived who need to be there to
actually take damage down in the end if
he's omniscient if the eye of agamotto
gives him the ability to see all
eventualities but if he's again like
Nicholas Cage in the movie next and he
can only see just a few minutes I had
any saw 40 further I think no matter
what we could argue that from star-lords
point of view a very selfish move
especially since he had several scenes
with Gamora where he was arguing on
whether or not he would kill her he
pulled the trigger
unfortunately bubbles came out and very
cartoonish hilarious way he was totally
ready to kill her and it seems like he
should have already detached himself at
least on a slight emotional level so
that when he's confronted with saving
half the known universe he can at least
hold that back but me were taking a
swing at the guy maybe I I kind of agree
yes it is his fault I do agree cuz I'm
actually just when you think about it
it's like yeah 100% it's his fault but
also I do like the perspective of like
know the end game when he mentions this
is the end game now it's that this is
the this is the last this is the you
have to complete what's gonna happen
next I gave you everything that you can
possibly know and have it your in your
arsenal and you can do this yeah I do
like I do think your theory is more
correctly we can also talk this up to
like in war just things happen nothing
should ever go to plan right it's a
little bit more sustained to see it's
way more interesting I would say to see
Peter quill screw up this place in the
movie what and we're not talking about
did he trip on a rock
he did something that his character
chose to do or maybe Dyneema chose just
to do because of the thing most
important to him in the world was gone
or in the universe really was gone
so he doesn't really have a great reason
to save the universe as much he used to
in that moment and the thing that did it
is right there in that moment so they
definitely justified it so we don't
necessarily need to even say the wrong
thing and I'll give you a twist on the
same question it could go all the way
the other way if dr. strange was right
this is the one time then is them
winning at the end of infinity war to
Peter Quill's fault oh yeah you could
yeah you could have these thought
experiments and infinite no it's just my
plan that's kind of yeah if it came back
around that way at least at least like
Danis didn't sit on his mixtape volume
two and that's why he was pissed off
well now it's time to move on to our new
rock stars news lightning round
you guys tweet us questions I'm gonna
fire them at my code so you guys ready
alright no Phillip at akram Lolo wants
to know should Thanos be more evil in
Part two should their nose be more evil
on planes waiting I would argue that he
was not evil in part one he was
motivated to think he was doing what was
best for the universe and I think he
should continue that in the next one Sam
at one fj CEO or old buddy wants to know
where the hell is valkyrie it's just in
the other half I mean if you're gonna
pick a leader for Asgardians she's your
best bet Korg meek you guys you got it
got around the troops you gotta come
help for the next movie
[Music]
hmmm this is my favorite would you
rather spend three days in the
west-world park during the host revolt
or 24 hours in Jurassic park's meltdown
just one day in Jurassic park's no no I
think I could survive one day with those
dumb dinosaurs Jeff Goldblum didn't see
any on the tour in the first movie you
just hide up in a tree and have the
Brachiosaurus sneeze on you that sounds
like fun
just don't get have the tree I can't
live a day in a tree wigs we got in the
pipeline for videos coming out this show
next week guys gonna be infinity week
part 2 pretty much we got our full movie
breakdown and mystery is coming coming
out next week
we're also we're some of the stuff that
we talked about in this video we're
gonna do more in depth look sad we
wanted to research research and and
really think about where this could go
so we want to look at what exactly dr.
Strange's plan could have been we want
to talk about Red Skull in this movie
what that means how he got there and how
that affected the movie and yeah we want
to talk about what the soulstone means
in what effect it has how it affects
Thanos's personality and what powers it
gives him so each of these things
keeping out four different theory videos
about each of these things it's gonna be
a lot of interest I'm very very excited
about what's coming up for us and
there's so much we just have so much
yeah
all throughout win ok well now comes the
time for a 15-second shout out where
each of us has 15 seconds to shout out
plug gram about anything we want
Sam take it away god of war ho boy Devon
yes we're both playing it is a beautiful
game yes it sort of a if you guys just
want I haven't played a video game all
the way through and quite at some time
and this is beautiful it's like one long
movie you want awesome movie about Norse
mythology go play that game it's a
peaceful Xbox
yeah you know sound like an a distant
parent that sounds like a wholesome use
of his time
at least he's not out with the gangs for
my 15 seconds out I've been catching up
on the HBO series insecure Issa Rae it's
so funny it's so great I mean I know I'm
Way behind on the times but God this
show is like it's everything I wanted
it's it's just super funny and the
relationships are so grounded and great
checkouts on HBO most of you have your
parents passwords just launched it yeah
shout out shout out Phillip he's been
thinking about my dad fading away
YouTube well fine let's return to a
trivia question that we last asked last
asked earlier and then yeah so just to
remind you guys what the question was in
Avengers infinity war Tony Stark brags
at Ben & Jerry's named ice cream flavor
after him stark raving hazelnuts while
responsa tea prefers another flavor what
was it Sam everyone's ripped by the way
says fish food food Phillip says Hoka
Hoka burning chocolate it might have
been like another made-up when they like
stuff well eric has my favorite the st.
yum sand bubblegum onto it here a
hunka-hunka burning fudge yeah so our
winner sounds like mr. fimo loser I did
yes seven is a big loser to this week I
guess a real flavor
well no yours was the worst why I love
fish food what but his was a pun on my
face
you just have no flavors of ice and a
bit summer made a mashup video yeah it's
a good one it's fantastic
it hurts gonna do our goodbyes first
we're gonna run through it in under the
news headlights I'll read the headline
Sam will have to riff cleverly oh we're
in for a treat
I'm so so excited okay save you ready
hey yes you are okay so the director of
the horror movie it promised that the
seat will be so scary that you'll need
to wear diapers because I am already
prepared I can depend two for the price
of one all right the latest venom
trailer showed Venom's horrifying face
and tongue Elizabeth Banks who played
Betty Brant in the earlier spider-man
movies tweeted said it looks like venom
is eating a dick oh yeah I hate it when
the joke gets stuck is in the mouth
probably show us your tongue next up
James Cameron who has for avatar sequels
in the work said that he hopes
moviegoers that's already the joke soon
get quote Avenger fatigue referring to
the MCU heroes as quote hyper gonna dole
males whoa pump the brakes there Cameron
alright
I don't remember one remember we speak
of dicks remember when Italian put the
dick in the dragon and he drove it no
it's a good joke that's what I have for
the movie you can go to on that
Disneyland right now right you remember
the magnet poetry oh man
I'm a disappointment
george RR martin announced that fire and
blood a prequel book set before the main
a song of ice and fire events will come
out on november 20th of this year and
that book six of the main book series
the winds of winter will not come out
this year man is more like winds of
disappointment more like that yeah more
like winds oh you're never gonna get
those books and and finally a company
has released a series of Avengers
infinity Wars themed sex toys including
the giant Hulk dildo named The
Incredible dong Thor hammer with a dildo
handle called monel near and the
infinity fist lit up that way no I will
never get lost again they aged a lot
during this segment I'm real sweaty this
week's episode of new rockstars news
since I won I get to do it as I like at
the end here so I'm gonna tell you true
embarrassing stories that I know about
these two as we go through them but they
might be lies but they definitely could
be true
but they might be lies but they're
probably true I want to thank our host
Sam basher who had diarrhea for a whole
week at SourceFed and still came into
work every day but left it in the toilet
one time and then everybody took
pictures and you can reach him at sam
basher Eric boss
a DEA boss went on a date once and when
he couldn't unhook a bra just left one
time I'm trying to hold the door open
the lock was broken in elementary school
and the bully open it she left without
pain and I didn't pay either and so she
she technically still hurt me at Maude
Garrett she wasn't here and then the
restaurant manager Kathy impending
comment down below and tweet us at new
rock stars too and like this video share
it around there's a lot of information
here about infinity war and there's a
lot more to come too so subscribe to new
rock stars because we're gonna give you
so many deep dives into more infinity
work online mostly and the other stuff
you guys love - we'll see you next week
Eric what do you do ends into the theme
music hey five people who stay through
my whole segment love you guys family